What's the best way to find the 'HCF' and 'LCM' of three numbers?
Let's say, we have to find the HCF an LCM of 70, 80 and 120.
We have to use a technique which gives us both together
the LCM as well as the HCF.
The best way to do that would be to reduce 70, 80
and 120 to its prime factors.
70 equals '2 times 5 times 7'.
80 is '16 times 5', which can be written as '2 raised to 4 times 5'.
And 120 is '15 times 8',
which in prime factor form can be written as '2 cubed times 3 times 5'.
What do we do now?
To keep it simple we can quickly make columns of the list of prime factors.
We have 2, 3, 5 & 7.
In 70, we have '2 raised to 1', '5 raised to 1' and '7 raised to 1'.
In 80, we have '2 raised to 4' and '5 raised to 1'.
And in 120 we have '2 cubed, '3 raised to 1' and '5 raised to 1'.
With this ready, we can easily find the HCF and the LCM.
HCF is the product of the least powers of shared factors.
As there are only two prime factors which are shared,
we look at only those two columns.
The least power in this column is 1.
So we write a '2 raised to 1'.
And in this column as well the least power is 1.
So we multiply this with '5 raised to 1'.
And the product equals 10.
The HCF of these three numbers is 10.
For the LCM we take the highest power of each factor.
The factors need not be shared.
The highest power in this column is 4.
We write it a '2 raised to 4' here.
In this column we have '3 raised to 1'.
Why is this the highest? Because others are '3 raised to 0'.
Third column, it's '5 raised to 1'.
And the fourth column, has '7 raised to 1' as the highest power.
This product equals 1680.
That's the LCM of 70, 80 and 120.
So we can see that with a simple column structure,
we can easily find the HCF and LCM of 3 numbers.